for them and 10 years ago when i
launched the munro review just going to
leave we're just going to leave the
commons
because the mother of the two sisters
murdered
in the case of the two police officers
who took pictures of the sisters is
speaking prepared i was going to say
well all of us have been in lockdown for
the last 18 months two years what's
different but i think the judge really
got it
um
and i think also the ground swell of
um
the public feeling
uh about this this story and and breach
of um
conduct
uh so i'm pleased
you know it's been 18
and what what does this sentence today
do in terms of you
moving on
it doesn't it's it's not not a day for
celebration
it never is
but this will be the first time
that we haven't had to stay on the
starting blocks
to come to the old bailey i hope i never
have to come back here again for any
other reason nothing at all so
the fam myself my husband my family
we've been to hell and back again
so um i haven't we haven't even done
what it's going to feel like not having
this hanging over your head
is this the final chapter
no
no no there's um
there's more work to be done
the most important thing is i think
because of the sentencing
we are part of the change that
say again
most of our politicians are amazing and
do amazing jobs but there is an element
that has taken over the culture
of um how they banter i mean you will
have heard what the whatsapp group name
is
and i don't know how you're going to put
that in the press and i can't say it
here but i hope you will do
covid and the bleep bleep bleeps
because um
it does matter the language that they
used it's an example of misogyny
in its worst possible
form
so it does matter these police force
as i said felt so secure in the way they
they behave that they could
do that as their their their subject
awful we heard in your victim's
statement that you said that those men
have dehumanized
your thoughts what we heard repeatedly
from their barristers is an enormous
remorse that they allegedly feel does
that go anyway to helping you
no because it's all still a bit of a
game
if you plead guilty you automatically
will get a third off your sentence
so
you know sorry i bet they are sorry you
know i bet they're sorry and tortured
that they've tortured their family i bet
they get stick everywhere that's not
quite the same as feeling shame
and i don't want to say anything i i was
going to say i don't want to say
anything derogatory about um
well what did they call it when you look
after the prisoners
parole
do you remember that the parole officer
gave them glowing reports and said um
you know they genuinely are remorseful
remember this is the same parole
officers that let uh you know uh
terrorists out they said oh no you can
come off probation now you're perfectly
safe
so
i as uh queen elizabeth the first said i
do not have windows into men's souls
but i would say
they are more sorry that they got caught
than they are about what they did
you know they've got caught with their
hands in the cookie jar
and now they're sorry
i feel sorry for their family
um i i've you know i know it's not going
to be easy for them
but it hasn't been easy for us
and this additional um
pain and suffering we've gone through
could have been avoided
um
and
it is heinous
and i i'm really pleased i think i'm
hoping this sends a signal
to
the met and all other police forces and
give strength to those who are being
abused and hearing language that they
detest
but are afraid to speak up that now is
the time speak up people will listen
quick questions
i just want women to feel safe or women
to feel safe that's my that's my major
message
we need to do more
um and we need to change we have good
laws in place but they're not enacted
they're not you know it we just need to
up our game and if i'm going to complain
about anything it's going to be on
behalf
of
women
all women
but women of color and i am so pleased
and thankful to you the media you've got
behind this and you've realized that i
haven't been criticizing you i've been
asking you the question and i've told
you to go back to your editors and say i
know it's not you
it's them and i am coming for them and i
am going to do that work as well you
know you're doing a good job
yes how important was it that that
person came forward and ticked off the
police watching the watchdogs
yeah they're amazing and i i want i hope
that one day we come to the point where
you don't have to be called a
whistleblower
actually you're just a good person
standing up for the other so if you're a
man and you're witnessing misogyny speak
up for the woman if you're white and you
hear somebody having a go about a black
person speak up for them if you're gay
and you know and you're you're not gay
and you hear someone speaking homophobia
speak up
now's the time the good people are the
ones that should have voice
they're the ones who should have the
power
that's me i'm i'm done
thank you thank you thank you